le livre d'affaires est comment
réussir comment revenir de l'
adversité comment gérer l'adversité
tendance
[Musique]
donc
et je suis allé dans une grande école de commerce
certains des
très grands génies qu'ils n'ont
pas rendus aussi grands que les
autres parce qu'ils ne savaient pas
comment gagner
[Musique] dans laquelle
nous avons grandi  une famille très raciste,
mon grand-père était à la fois antisémite raciste
et misogyne, donc c'était amusant
euh donc Donald a grandi
avec ces choses comme une seconde nature
et
euh j'ai souvent entendu des insultes raciales des
insultes antisémites proférées à propos de
vous savez avec désinvolture  dans ma famille
[Musique]
[Rires]
Bon, nous mangeons notre pizza dans le mauvais sens la
croûte en premier
[Musique]
donc
peut-être qu'en fait il est temps
pour un homme d'affaires d'être président
peut-être que quelqu'un devrait  regarder la
ligne
de fond de th  La vraie grande entreprise a appelé
le gouvernement des États-Unis, la façon dont
ils surveillent les résultats d'une entreprise
peut-être que cela devrait se produire
vous êtes viré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ne montre-t-il pas le
certificat de naissance et pourquoi dépense-t-il des
millions de  dollars en frais juridiques pour
s'éloigner de ce problème
et laissez-moi vous dire qu'il n'aime pas
donald trump
et le dernier gars au monde contre lequel il
veut se présenter est donald trump
personne n'est plus heureux personne n'est plus fier
de mettre cette naissance  le certificat importe plus
que l'atout de donald
et c'est parce qu'il peut enfin
se concentrer
sur les problèmes qui comptent, comme
avons-nous simulé l'atterrissage sur la lune,
ce qui s'est réellement passé à roswell
et où sont biggie et tupac
[Rires]
quand le mexique envoie son peuple ils  ils n'envoient pas de
leur mieux
ils ne vous envoient pas ils ne
vous envoient pas
ils envoient des gens qui ont beaucoup de
problèmes
et ils apportent ces problèmes avec
nous
ils apportent de la drogue ils apportent le
crime
ils  les violeurs et certains, je suppose, sont de
bonnes personnes
[Musique]
nous rendrons l'Amérique formidable
[Musique] à
nouveau
[Musique]
donc
c'était difficile c'était difficile
ce truc politique est méchant et c'est
difficile
donc je tiens à remercier ma famille beaucoup
[Music]
donc
je dirai que c'est du génie de l'autre côté
peut-être encore plus parce qu'ils n'ont rien pris
et m'ont amené à un vote final d'
impeachment
c'est un mot très laid pour moi c'est un
mot très sombre très laid
mais maintenant nous  avoir ce mot magnifique je
n'ai jamais pensé qu'un mot sonnerait si bien
ça s'appelle un acquittement total
si je perds contre lui je ne sais pas ce que je
vais faire je ne
te parlerai plus jamais tu ne me verras jamais
toi